hello and thank you for attending this
talk so my name is Wade Elliot I am a
research chemist at the National
Institute of Standards and Technology
and I'm going to be presenting some data
on some of the current methods and
metrics for chemo to metric analysis of
NMR spectroscopy methodologies for
analyzing monoclonal antibody
therapeutics in their higher order
structure so to give a very brief
outline of what I'm going to be covering
in the next twenty to thirty minutes I'm
going to discuss a little bit about
monoclonal antibodies and more
importantly why we care about being able
to analyze their higher order structure
and why we care about the chemo metric
aspect of that I'm going to dive a
little bit into a couple of different
methods that have been published and
some of the studies we've been
performing along with those methods to
show the robustness and and usefulness
of the techniques and then I'm going to
present a little bit on the utilization
of lower field lower resolution in more
spectroscopy as a modality for screening
protein therapeutics so monoclonal
antibodies currently command a very
large portion of the pharmaceutical
revenue stream as you can see here this
slide from the sales of the top ten
selling drugs in 2017
the overwhelming majority of these are
monoclonal antibodies or protein
therapeutics and so as you can tell with
this much money being poured into
research and development it's very
important that we have well-established
methodologies in order to be able to
analyze these these therapies
furthermore as the years progress from
the time that these drugs are developed
there we get closer and closer to the
time in which these monoclonal antibody
therapies and other protein therapies
are going to come off patent to make way
for a
wave in the biosimilar production realm
why that's important is the way that we
just evaluate and determine the
usefulness and safety and efficacy of
these protein therapeutics is inverse
between the originators and the
biosimilars so when we deal with
originators typically we do some
developmental analytical work we then
proceed into some non clinical based
tests and trials and then we move into a
clinical trial where we determine the
potency the efficacy as well as the
safety however with respect to
biosimilars we do the opposite paradigm
where we spend most of our time
analyzing the actual molecular species
themselves to make sure that they are in
fact similar and then we do a little bit
less into the non clinical and clinical
methodologies with the understanding
that as long as the structure is within
a specific realm of similarity that
realistically the functionality should
be the same so why is in Tamar
spectroscopy useful with respect to
protein therapeutics
well NMR is unique in that we can get
very very specific information with
respect to individual atoms along with
individual amino acids in the protein
and how they're interacting with each
other so one problem that is presented
though with respect to monoclonal
antibodies versus of small peptide or a
small protein such as ubiquitin or GV
one is that mAbs are the very very large
end of the spectrum by comparison they
averaged around 150 kilo daltons and
because of that the motion of these
proteins in solution is very slow and
that's something that is disadvantageous
with respect to NMR so as you can see
here there is a spectrum of a proton and
nitrogen correlation this allows us to
look specifically at that a Madrid of
the
backbone of the protein one of the
problems with NMR besides the necessary
or the need for fast motion in solution
in this case is the low rate of NMR
active naturally abundant isotopes so
protons for example exist that nearly
100 percent natural abundance which
allows us to take full advantage of all
of the hydrogen atoms or at least the
overwhelming majority of hydrogen atoms
in in our sample conversely nitrogen 15
in this case exists at a less than 1%
natural abundance which means that for
every 100 excuse me for every 100
nitrogen atoms that are in the protein
we are only seeing about 0.5 of them or
0.3 actually 0.37 so that makes it much
less sensitive than some of the other
techniques out there now we can get
around this by doing things like
isotopic enrichment but when we're
dealing with drug products that is
usually something that not is not
regularly done which is I stopped the
enrichment of the protein which means
that we have to find other ways to be
able to get anymore data especially
specifically things like these NMR
fingerprints that I'm showing here so
there was a few years ago a method that
was presented all profile which stands
for protein fingerprinting based on
white shape enhancement the idea is that
you utilize proton NMR which has a very
high resolution very high sensitivity
and you have a very high natural
abundance of protons in your sample and
you can get these very detailed spectra
in this case with this profile
experiment we're collecting a postal
gradient stimulated echoes that type of
experiment which is a fancy type of
diffusion experiment which allows us to
get rid of any of the excipient and
suppress the water signal so all we see
is the protein
um what we then do with this data
in the profile method is we file
gaussian line broadening function to
produce this contour spectrum that you
see then do some subtraction of the
originals excuse me of the contour
spectrum from the original spectra and
we're able to produce this fingerprint
what we can do from there is take it a
step further and we can take this
fingerprint spectra and compare it to
the fingerprint spectra of other protein
therapeutics or protein therapeutics
from the same law so we can get an idea
of similarity or dissimilarity now a few
years ago a couple years after the
profile paper was published our group
here at NIST published a paper on using
methyl groups as the as a method of
fingerprinting things like higher order
structure and fingerprinting antibodies
specifically these monoclonal antibodies
the idea with this is that from a
natural abundance perspective carbon 13
which is an NMR active isotope exists at
about a three times rate to that of
nitrogen 15 this means it's so much more
sensitive technique than the previous or
the couple previous slides I showed
where I showed the nitrogen or proton
nitrogen hsq see this allows us to get
more detailed information and in
addition to that as you can see on the
picture on the right the methyl groups
are very evenly dispersed throughout the
entirety of the antibody which gives us
information about localized higher order
structure changes from the secondary
structure tertiary structure and even
potentially the Quinton Airy structure
and quaternary structure depending on
what kind of interactions and changes we
see so we're able to collect very
detailed data the first spectra you're
seeing here is at 900 megahertz which is
a very high field NMR and we can even go
at slightly lower field with at 600 NMR
or excuse me 600 megahertz which is also
still a high field NMR
okay so what we can do with this data is
we can collect these spectra and compare
them and generates similarity
information all based on types of
correlations in this case I'm showing a
linear correlation analysis between two
different antibodies which the spectra
we see up in the upper left hand corner
we can then bend this data and do a
direct correlation embarrassin and in
this case get an ARS our statistical
value to give us a relative similarity
so we took these two methods and we
decided to run a multi lab study in
order to determine if these two
methodologies which have been published
are in fact comparable and so as you can
see here there's a list of numerous
blends of antibodies along with antibody
types in which we can go through and
actually do some comparability studies
between the 1d method and the 2d method
now all of these spectra were collected
on the list of NMR spectrometers that
you see at the bottom and we were able
to take that data and do some
interesting things and then find out
some interesting things which I'm gonna
start showing you in just a couple
slides so here we have a list of the
correlations that we performed after we
collected the data and as you can see
it's a symmetrical correlation which
allows us to skip a little bit of extra
work what we did in the as far as the
experimental details are concerned with
the 1d experiments as I stated
previously we run a full shell gradient
stimulated echo experiment each of these
experiments take approximately two hours
actually ran off an hour and 30 minutes
to complete we collected five data sets
per sample and then we processed
initially the data in topspin using some
gaussian line broadening some the
automatic phasing as well
taking a step further and applying the
profile processing scripts in a lap with
respect to the 2d data we collected
grading hsq seas with water suppression
each of these excuse me experiments took
about two and a half hours and we
collected two data sets per sample the
processing was then performed an NMR
pipe with cosine Bell squared operation
and since these experiments typically
take fairly long to do we acquired at
50% onion form sampling so we use ist
reconstruction and some automatic
phasing and then they cross correlation
analysis in MATLAB so what I'm going to
show you here is some of the profile
data for the 1d correlations that we did
what this is representing is the first
four samples so sample one being igg1
a or sample one a sample two is an IgG
one which is a sample B sample 3 is the
digest of sample1 and sample2 and what
you can see is the correlation from each
of these spectrometers is actually very
very similar to the others so the trend
is very it is very similar between these
and spectrometers and that gives us good
information that this technique is with
respect to these samples at least very
robust and just to illustrate the point
a little bit more these are the
correlations on bar graphs so you can
see that the relative correlations that
are calculated are actually very very
similar across the different spectra for
the 2d data we performed as I said a
linear correlation in MATLAB and you may
notice that some of the data is a little
bit different I'm gonna go into that
just in just a few seconds the samples
we're looking at are the same samples
that we looked at with respect to the 1d
data and you will also see that the 2d
data is very comparable within its own
subset of 2d data
and once again the bar graph illustrates
that this that each of the spectrometers
gives you fairly similar data but as I
mentioned you do see that the trend
between the 1d profile method and the 2d
cross-correlation method are slightly
different and I'm just gonna highlight a
couple of instances now the the circles
that I'm highlighting of these box and
whisker plots are illustrating
specifically in this case the comparison
between the IgG 1a and the IgG one a
digest now the reason we're seeing this
discrepancy not just with respect to
this one but some of the other
discrepancies in there has to do with
the size differential and I mentioned
earlier that size with respect NMR
spectroscopy is fairly important so if
we look at the 2 D spectrum of sample 1
which is the IgG 1a and sample 2 which
is the digest we can see that they don't
match so the digest is the fuchsia color
and the gray is the IgG one or the
sample one as you can see there are
Peaks that show up with respect to the
digest and do not show up with respect
to the intact product the reason for
that has to do with what is known as
chemical shift day and I saw trippy so
larger molecules rotate or tumble at a
much slower rate and because of that we
experienced a significant amount of line
broadening so in order to compensate for
that we typically need to acquire our
data for longer or take more scans of
our data
this was actually illustrated a few
years back in a paper produced out of
this out of our group as well that doing
or performing a domain cleavage meaning
doing a digest of the intact map into
its fa b and FC domains does not
actually alter the higher order
structure but we just require more scans
of the intact map in order to be able to
dig down deeper and and account for the
line broadening so we did additional
correlations outside of just
those four samples I showed you and as
you can see once again profile for the
most part across the spectrometers gives
you fairly comparable data with respect
to the 700 megahertz spectrometer data
you will see that there is some
discrepancy with there compared to the
other three and that is due mostly in
part to an issue that was issue with
water suppression of the of the sample
setup or the experimental setup so there
the reason that is the reason that ADA
doesn't necessarily match if we go over
to the 2d methyl fingerprinting data of
the same sample correlations we begin to
see a very significant discrepancy
between our across all of the
spectrometers with the exception of the
600 megahertz
a and 900 megahertz spectrum the reason
for that well and I'll get into that in
a minute I want to show you the data
first so sample 12-day our sample 12
which is a blended sample this is the
spectrum of the sample taken at 900
megahertz and I will point out that the
900 megahertz spectrometer data is
actually the some of the very first data
that was collected if we look at it
compared to the 600 megahertz
spectrometer data um you will see that
there are some significant discrepancies
with the data and that has to do with
the fact that the 600 megahertz spectrum
are 600 meters B data was actually
collected at the very end of the study
which was close to a year later we see
that with respect to the blended sample
sample 11 the same kind of discrepancy
and sample 10 which is also a different
percentage of the same kind of blended
sample we see once again a discrepancy
in and I'm just highlighting in these
cases just some of the peaks that that
change and then some of the deviations
we see so what we were able to conclude
about this is that there was some form
of sample degradation over time in this
case we
you see is the methyl fingerprint of the
spectra collected at 600 megahertz of
one of the samples and the blue is the
initial data that was collected which
was the very first spectroscopic data
collected on this sample or the very
first spectrometer used and then we see
in the red the data collected on the
exact same sample after year on the
exact same spectrometer and as you don't
need to be in a more spectroscopy to be
able to see that there is distinct
difference between the two samples this
tells us that there's some kind of
change occurring whether it's a change
in higher order structure or some form
of chemical modification that is
occurring so flush this out a little bit
more we collected some mass spectroscopy
data on it and compared it to what we
expect to actually see I'm so in the
first column from the left you see the
NIST the title for NIST map RM 86 71
which is what samples 10 11 and 12 are
also but at blended States and you can
see the relative amount of oxidation
occurring at each of the specific
methines associated with that as you
move across the board you can see that
each of these samples has some oxidation
occurring at different sites so as you
can see here Metheny in 34 has a
significant amount of oxidation compared
to what you would expect to find methane
101 has probably the highest level of
oxidation compared to what you'd expect
to find and then methionine 255 also has
for the most part some extensive
oxidation as well which goes to explain
why we are seeing what is occurring in
those spectra so to just illustrate some
of the outcomes that we've seen from
this study one the profile method and
the 2d fingerprinting method for the
most part provide a fairly comparable
data in these instances that we showed
with the exception of being that the
the degraded samples were less sensitive
or less able to be detected by the 1d
method or the 1d profile method I should
say than the 2d fingerprinting method
and this could be due in part to the
fact that when you add an extra
dimension of detection you can pick up
on a few more things that you maybe
won't necessarily be able to pick up on
with 1d if it's a very low level of
chemical modification now if these were
most more extensive you would probably
see that in profile quite well so from
that I want to move on to some work that
we've been doing that is very much
related to this using low resolution
techniques of NMR as a screening
technique for higher order structure one
of the issues that we run into as NMR
spectroscopy is most people think that
you need a very big super expensive high
field magnet under megahertz instrument
which is going to run in the range of
millions of dollars in order to acquire
these kinds of spectral data so we
wanted to go and see if we could
actually acquire good data and if it was
capable of giving us the information
that we wanted at low field so here we
use four different samples which I have
listed and we acquired the same kind of
diffusion experiments that you would
collect using profile so the post field
gradient stimulated echo experiments and
we did this at 600 megahertz but with a
cryoprobe but we also did this at a
lower field at 400 megahertz with a room
temperature probe and for those who
aren't don't know what I'm talking about
as far as the differences the lower and
field strengths you go obviously the
less the sensitivity but you also lose a
significant amount of sensitivity when
you use a room temperature probe instead
of a cryo probe and the reason we wanted
to look at these specific setups is many
companies have access to a 400 megahertz
NMR with this with a standard probe much
fewer or many fewer companies have
access to higher field issues such as
six seven eight and 900
it's in Amar's with very expensive cryo
platform system setup so we collected
this data and what we were able to
decipher is that using the profile
method so this is the 1d data that was
processed using the profile correlation
analysis we see a similar trend across
the board with these samples the issue
lies in the scaling of the difference of
these samples or the correlation
similarity of these samples so if you
look on the left the left column the two
spectra are the two plots you see on the
left are both at 600 megahertz with
1,000 scans this data takes
approximately an hour and 30 minutes to
acquire and and the top and bottom are
the exact same data points I just
organized that way to illustrate a point
if you look on the right column the two
box spots the top is at 256 scans using
a 400 megahertz spectrometer and the
bottom is at 512 scans using a 400
megahertz spectrometer the difference in
time is at 512 using this setup it takes
approximately 40 ish minutes to acquire
a spectrum and at 206 scans it takes
approximately 20 minutes to acquire the
spectrum so in 256 scans we can acquire
essentially five spectra to get somewhat
significant statistical values in
roughly the time it takes to acquire one
spectrum at 600 megahertz with 1000
scans now as I mentioned previously the
issue that we run into here is while the
trend is the same if you look at the
y-axis scales on these box plots you'll
notice that the 600 megahertz day it
only goes down to about 0.85
in the correlation value while the 400
megahertz data goes down to around 0.5
so we do see a similar trend but we
don't see the statistical value that's
being output being the same and that
does pose somewhat of a problem if we
are trying to go across field strings so
we are looking at a different method of
trying to analyze this data
we can get somewhat statistically more
meaningful data so can we use principle
component analysis to do this well PCA
or principal component analysis has been
used on several occasions to analyze 2d
NMR spectra specifically the methyl
fingerprinting method and what I'm
showing here is from a paper that was
recently published in our group where
they did a cross or an inter laboratory
study and were able to use PCA to
cluster the different sample types
regardless of the spectrometer that was
used or the user so the thought process
was well at low field strength with low
resolution we're probably not going to
be able to acquire 2d data but can we do
this kind of analysis for 1d data so
here we applied where we try to apply
that thought process so you see a series
of 1d spectra that were collected and
does it work well we think so and we're
still refining this but we're able to
acquire 1d data at low field this is 400
megahertz with 512 scans of each of
these samples took about 40 minutes to
acquire or each and as you can see the
clustering is very good from pca and not
only is the clustering very good but the
variation between clusters the distance
between clusters is fairly pronounced so
we can actually see a difference we're
currently in the process of developing a
method in order to determine whether or
not what we're seeing is statistically
significant so that's a still a work in
progress but at this point it's very
promising and we're hoping to be able to
push this out the door in the very near
future so just as a quick summary - I'll
review everything 1d profile and 2d
fingerprinting both provide comparable
data as long as we are using a linear
correlation algorithm we are looking at
developing PCA methods for 1d and seeing
if that gives us similar information to
what we would expect
we did see that 2d methyl fingerprinting
is a little bit more sensitive to low
levels of chemical modification then the
profile method was but we're also
testing to see if if the PCA method can
give us a similar kind of output on the
1d data we also found that low level or
low field low resolution 1d spectroscopy
methods are sufficient for screening at
least and but more robust statistical
analysis need to be implemented to make
it really something that can be useful
to the pharma industry and then the 1d
PCA method we're actually developing
into a toolkit in a more pipe and
hopefully we'll be able to put that out
the door to give other people access to
the ability and with that I would like
to thank and acknowledge people who are
involved in this study in these studies
so dr. Luke Arbogast and this the dr.
Matt's face drum at Amgen dr. John
marina at NIST dr. Frankel uglyness dr.
Wrenn salinas and doctors yves amon and
amon Gus Ronnie at Health Canada and
then doctors John Gibbs and John she'll
also hear and his to provided us with
and with that I would like to thank all
of you for attending and listening